for cows is all it takes to run a biogas
plant in Bangladesh the dung they
produce is fed into the plant which then
produces methane the equipment costs
3600 euros nazmal faisal tells us that
they've installed almost 70,000 plants
already with funding from Germany
natella gone under firmly now have
electricity and gas for cooking there's
even enough left over to sell to the
neighbours that helps because the family
has to cover 15 percent of the original
costs themselves live here we used to
have lots of problems but now it's much
better I can cook and do other things at
the same time there's no smoke either
sticks dipped in cow dung are however
still the most common heating fuel for
Bangladesh is pour this water pumping
station in the southwest of the country
is powered by the Sun because energy
from the solar panels drives the water
pump the farmers don't need to hold
diesel in anymore in lieu of the water
they have to give away some of their
produce still now they're able to bring
in an extra rice harvest they complain
that fertilizer and seeds have become
more expensive but it meant that over
all the solar power system has made life
easier here is remanded kine and as you
can see there's no connection to the
energy grid here so normally people
would use diesel to power the pumps
solar panels are of course cleaner
energy than diesel and more sustainable
the farmers also profit from solar
energy in the long run because they
don't have to pay for diesel all the
time I didn't a diesel but I listened
these solar panels are another success
story 4 million masts just like this one
have been built so far 80% of
Bangladeshis live rurally often without
any kind of power the panel's produce
enough electricity to load a phone and
provide light at night
simple solutions that can make an
enormous difference